hello and welcome to another crazy
episode so we're on the road and i'm
coming to your city you can get tickets
right now literally this weekend i'm
coming to salt lake city you can get
tickets at esthernice.com i cannot wait
for salt lake city the next weekend i'm
in nashville and then i'm coming to
raleigh
um my austin days are being rescheduled
and i'm coming to indianapolis
philadelphia san diego and chicago and
more get all those tickets at
esteronice.com and check out my clothing
line sleepover by esther.com happy 2022
sluggies come see me on the road i'm
going to be out there all year come see
me this month at the milwaukee improv
i'll be in naples florida and tampa
florida and a bunch more dates coming up
please look on andy lederman.com shows
there are so many dates i can't wait to
meet you
[Music]
how about when my i tell her my hair
caught on fire she goes dude was it on
film
did i catch it
what is going on look at how pretty look
at how this is what real pretty women
look like i just want everyone to know
it's clashing colors but that's her
thing those are power cup colors pink
power couple power colors
pink i'm sorry are we talking about your
self tanner or are you talking about i
did your personality what are you
talking about i did it for you i am also
by the way wearing a turtleneck it's
very cold out and i was driving over
here and i went no one's ever been funny
an eternal neck that's not there's no
every mime every mom
wearing a turtleneck like diane keaton
that shots fired when when in what movie
i'll do this right now i've never
thought woody allen movies are funny
i've never wow we get it she was ahead
of the molestation
you knew before all of us you want to
just do this she's like the cosby show
was trash i always knew it what do you
love the cosby show woody allen movies
are like an old jewish man's game so you
like them no i'm not a woody allen movie
fan i never have been i pretended to be
for a while yeah i maybe was pretending
to because i think about it like what
did i like on a few dates you know i was
i love andy hall of course
why why because i used to pretend to be
someone i wasn't why are we pretending
we like this first of all why is
dangerous okay fine i hate your
sweatshirt
i'm coming in in a complete existential
crisis yes everything
i'm coming in going i do not understand
podcasting i do not understand comedy i
am quitting all day we're so glad to
hear this none of the ways this is
working i don't thank you for finally
realizing right now we've been trying to
get rid of you this whole [ __ ] time
she decides to quit when she shows up at
our show and then she's like oh my god
our ratings would be huge whitney's last
podcast
thank you whitney i'm retiring oh trash
jesus can you not hide a lot of podcasts
oh whitney the hitler thought more of a
that was like just an old lady white
lady dance i think what i just did it
was embarra even more embarrassing than
doing like awesome did you think about
the socks when you put the pinkies on
you know you know what i basically
i dress now like if i was in a cult what
would i wear that's how i get dressed up
oh it is very cosy i'll be in your cult
tell me more about it yeah if i was like
oh my god she just completely ignored
you the one thing
leader is to just get as many people as
possible and she drew the line at you
her first member
the fact that i was like driving over
here to come get insulted by women and
wigs i'm in a call i just don't
understand why you do this if you have a
tesla just buy the one that drives for
you [ __ ] i don't have a towel oh yeah
that's right you have your uh i don't
have a tesla anymore because uh benton
and i for thanksgiving went to a friend
of ours in malibu the power went out and
uh in malibu there was no power in
malibu i was like i'm gonna take bent
into this fancy celebrity thanksgiving
like give him a nice thanksgiving fun
fun this like famous musician's house
power goes out in malibu i we had a lot
to drink
because i
music people make me uncomfortable i
don't know what to do oh you got june
shine now you got a sponsor you have
your own drink what do you know rudy
jenner was
he was talking about his um alcoholic
water
alcoholic water and he's like so great
and hydrates you and gets you drunk
that's awesome like all these things now
where we're like this is like vitamin
water yeah with tequila
oh my god it's my favorite part
what's up with whitney because i do fall
in love with her every time it's really
weird yeah of course wait who's who's
thanksgiving where are you at are we
like oh wait i don't like can i say
let's see later
i know oh my god that's such a twist so
benjen loves avril lavigne i love avril
lavigne yes uh i love
you know writing with numbers yeah i
can't you know and so i'm like we got to
go to this i did a movie with her
husband or fiance i don't know how that
works but no more some 31 guys
she was married to some 31 girls before
no she was married to the nickelback guy
wasn't she
she was married to someone where i went
avril gosh i'm i don't know
like you're in the moment you're not in
her past
you know what it was i i think i was in
like
avril like i was very into her music but
i was more of a like tori amos fiona
apple liz faire like
mess yeah at the time i was like fun we
were even i didn't get it
you're like i've been a bad bad girl
yeah i don't know that i was like yeah
it's just me and a gun
i was like
in a different place i was driving over
here i was like who do i blame all this
on like i've had a
such an epiphany the last couple days
because i'm like i just feel like a such
a failure right now no
what's going on no it's like i just was
like what like there's no blueprint for
what any of us are doing right no that's
the fun part which is it's like this
wild west craziness
the the women or men or whatever that
came before us
all the things that they've accomplished
uh
the ways they accomplished it don't
exist anymore correct and the
accomplishments don't exist anymore of
course so
what are we working towards i tell you
yeah being in the moment and enjoying it
i disagree oh annie i gotta do ayahuasca
with you no oh my god really you do i
feel like i do can i tell you oh my god
esther the grown-ups are talking you
know drugs annie bringing this whole
mental health thing into comedy is
really breaking my brain it's same for
annie what a plot twist i think that
everything that we're all doing which is
this like
incredibly
toxic
impossible female friendship thing
am i the only one that doesn't hold on
most people do it
for free
we at least get some kind of money for
it so i do see a benefit i i think that
female friendships are hard whether
you're in business or not right but when
you add that business things get rid of
we have decided to go like you know what
female friendships are so [ __ ] hard
why don't we just go into business
together and make it even harder and
make money off of it yeah i already hate
you
we might as well just like but there is
a there's like a zen and a calmness to
it too when you're like we have this
common goal to just like talk for an
hour or whitney's pockets seven hours
to just get it to just you just get
through it and then you appreciate each
other
yeah i think it's you know what it is i
think this is our mma this is our ufc
okay so like the bros they've got all
their fighter companion fighter in the
kid fighter bro like that's they're
physically fighting we kind of like i
got girl fight companion and it's just
us going over our own fights with each
other it's us just esther's crying no
because i just realized of course it's
whitney and annie of course i need to
keep my mouth shut i have no chance
i have no idea
this is your problem rise up [ __ ] rise
up we're not dimming down you rise up i
have no chance today
and i'm fine with it oh my god kalila
coming in is going to be even crazier
i have a question i learned about you
being single on dumois what's up with
that
yeah you should take a good hard look at
yourself and
realize that i'm not your friend
and why you believe that and that i'm a
fan why you think it's true why you know
so um
i guess it's like i don't know if i'm
single or not that's been my 20-year
struggle i have a question just ma'am
may i get i'm flying tomorrow my dog
gets a little crazy may i text alex to
get meds from my dog
i was dating a veteran do i have
permission to continue to use the hookup
of course not a man that i've ever dated
that has procured drugs for my friends
you can continue
texting them oh that's the problem
that's part of the agreement okay part
of the agreement is even if we break up
you have to continue giving drugs to my
friends
and their doctors thank god that was i
gotta i gotta meet your peptide or your
um your
academy doctor
oh my gosh she's here
i mean angel hi
hello a sweatpanted angel
here's the thing about y'all listening
watching whatever you're doing
the four of us in here we're all real
friends
and we've had no time to catch up off
camera so it's incredibly toxic and
awkward to show up to try to like it's
perfect it'd be having conversations
for public consumption before we've
caught up privately but i feel like
we're doing a pretty good job but we can
always edit out anything you want do
don't forget that well no you guys you
want the real uh oh and i want the real
i want the real purple's gonna look cute
although my relationship with you
whitney is a very healthy one because it
only involves dogs
i respect that
i respect that about you i feel like our
threads are just dog dog dogs dog dog
dog like you're like i need a vet i need
an er i hear you just i just get
pictures of like
boxers with two legs at 4 am i'm like
there's my like
i know how to do that mine with whitney
is it's not dog it's just dodge dodge
whitney just trying to get out of things
stop dodge dog
doge she's like i'm dogecoin
[Laughter]
you are my number one priority and you
guys know that that is the saddest lie
the most blatant one
and
you actually in my heart are that's the
weirdest part about all of this is that
this took so long to schedule and i feel
like i'm bombing no whitney what are you
talking about and i feel like y'all are
my priority and for me wendy's been to
texas guys so she says you all know oh
my gosh sorry
um i'm just getting older and you know
whatever i'm just trying to
um we saw the turtleneck well you're
from like the south right yeah that's
the other thing is yeah uh west virginia
and texas is my in december you're from
texas too my mom's from texas yeah
really yeah
i cannot wait till to hang out
for us to i feel like we are so close
no we have a tech side with rogan that
goes every day yeah yeah we are like i
feel like all of us are so close
but we all have so much like ketchup to
do and i feel like we all have to do
like one weekend of camping where we
like go like so where did you grow up
exactly who's oh that i thought it was
george i was like yeah george was like
great idea
i would love to go camping i i was gonna
say like you just saying that out loud
i'm like
you're going camping alone with me let's
do it oh no
one hide the body i'll help you can i
just say something about the dog blaze
why do your dogs hate you
my dogs don't hate me they hate each
other and i hate myself so you die and
you love them more than yourself i dive
in between them to stop them from
fighting and let's be honest scars are
sexy and painkillers feel great and i
always look for excuses you heal fast
too like you're always like you're like
have a wound and then you're fine like
two days later uh yeah i think we never
got like when he's addicted to drugs
whitney's addicted to this my main
addiction is fostering dogs and
attention that in attention uh fostering
dogs that uh uh should have been put
down years ago
frankly and so i i tend to take in these
really complicated
um cases of dogs that are
really traumatized that can't be with
other dogs and
with all the chaos in my life and people
in the house and
stuff going on
and having five dogs they end up
a mistake's gonna get made dogs attack
each other they're incredibly big
incredible it's kind of a miracle that
you can have people over because you
know i have a lot of dogs and they're
all [ __ ] up like yours and i just
can't have people over anymore because
they're all dick biters shop don't adopt
you know i mean not all of them do you
guys think that when guys date us that
they're they feel the same way they're
like this is a rescue like i just have
to be more patient oh she's a dick biter
i also see bobby as sort of a rescue
foreigner we all do yeah yeah
but i like a good rescue you know it's
in my wheelhouse i identify as a rescue
i have a weird take on bobby yeah what
is your take on bobby
i think bobby's better
like healthier and better than we all
think i think you're not wrong i think
there's a little bit of a like old story
going on with bobby
that's like
you're you're on nine tv shows you have
huge podcasts like
you you're doing great you know i think
there's a little bit of a because i feel
this too where it's like the things that
i used to joke about 10 years ago
people still joke about so i feel like i
have to still participate in it but do
you also think there's there's an
anxiety of when you do kind of like get
the things that you want that it's going
to get taken so then you kind of you
stay in that pattern too
yeah and it's going to get taken whether
you
yeah
i don't think it's in our control
yeah i don't think it's like in our
control whether it gets taken or not i
think bobby's also afraid of leaving
that old narrative about himself yeah
for sure so he doesn't like um being
viewed as
grown up almost that's because to me
like bobby's got like daddy energy like
and beyond that like i have never seen
anyone more committed to therapy no
matter where he travels whether it's
hungary or if he's on set he's not
missing a therapy session well here's
what we'll say
i came so our experience with bobby is
just so different because i opened for
bobby on the road yeah i like look up to
bobby like bobby was huge when i was a
little kid comic yeah you know so it's
like he like to me
is so why so the idea that it's like oh
bobby this is such a mess i'm like what
do you mean i look up to you and also
whenever he feels like he's like not
successful whatever i'm like you've been
successful my entire life
with feeling good
about himself like he's just so like
chaos is his baseline he's never known
anything different yeah you know he
doesn't realize that being bored and
stable is where like the healing happens
he just always is up you know he he
almost chases the instability because he
thinks yeah that that's where his
identity i have a hot taste i think you
guys are all wrong
i think
that's just because someone has success
and all these things i i think he's
still is probably feeling like he's the
same person yeah and it's not like
imposter syndrome not imposter syndrome
just like you don't none of these
outside things change who you are on the
inside uh well you haven't seen me in
the last six months
and it is literally a different view
i don't know i just feel like that
because i feel like
you know like 12 years ago when i moved
here to like quote unquote make it
versus how i feel now like i thought
that like having money and like a little
bit of success would solve all my
problems and it absolutely didn't and
like that's why i'm on medication and
stuff so
the hair doesn't help
i was just thinking of how many times
you did this
got a new move but you guys everyone in
this room is successful like whitney
don't you wait carlos don't make carlos
feel bad
whitney don't you feel like you're the
same person you were before you like
became like whitney cummings i don't
know uh
same issues deep down but you're just
working on them more yeah i just like i
think that like something happens at
least something happened to me recently
where i was like i'm just so sick of
myself talking about myself or thinking
about myself like i think there's a
point where you gotta
you know stop talking about yourself and
thinking about and obsessing about
yourself so for me like i i enjoy
podcasting like i went really hard at it
like my favorite people on the planet do
it like you guys but i think i just like
have hit a limit where i'm like i think
i need to not think about myself for a
while or talk about myself i need a
break
you also are such like an ep like you're
just such an executive producer in your
mind all it's like in your life like you
just everything you do you like you
produce it so well but it's so when
you're podcasting you're putting so much
into it you're like having an nbc show
every episode
it's stupid yeah no i don't think it's
stupid i think it's admirable but it's
like it's a lot of work are you able to
really take a break like for one month
just completely like disconnect is that
in your i think i i think this this is
maybe the year i i will be able to do
that you know in the past i had a really
hard time with um
uh i my self-esteem was definitely very
linked to my productivity you know and
how much i did even if it was a false
sense of productivity um and i think
there's this this very real like
you're a woman in hollywood and you
you've got to like 40 if you're lucky so
i think for me i was like i'm going to
[ __ ] cr like go hard till i'm 40 and
then chill like that was always i think
in the back of my mind like i'm not
going to take any breaks till then and
then um
and then
other stuff changed and then i realized
it wasn't 40 it was 30.
i had missed it i i was waiting i have
some really bad news it's 21.
i was wrong about the amount of time i
thought i had in the first place
i always thought you needed all these
additives and crazy ingredients
to have
delicious smelling armpits but not with
native okay native does me well and i
have armpit issues okay
and native makes it so easy to switch to
a personal care brand that makes all
their products with simple healthy
ingredients okay
native cares about the products that you
put on your body they're all about
stopping the stink the right way which i
need thank god for native and that's the
native difference natives coconut and
vanilla scented aluminum free deodorant
has been a customer favorite for years
and now native is on a mission to
overhaul your entire hygiene routine
they create products that are made with
simple ingredients like shea butter and
coconut oil so you can smell great all
day long what i love about native
deodorant is for me it checks all the
boxes that i needed to check it's
aluminum free
24-hour odor protection
zero residue on your skin when they when
you applicate it like there's none of
that and there's over 10 cents to choose
from so for me like i can switch it up i
don't get bored you know native also has
these cute plastic free tubes
and those are the ones perfect little
travel size as well those are the ones
that i keep you can create you can order
like you can order them in different
bundles if you want to try out different
scents and now is the time to treat
yourself with native and if you visit
their site you'll find not just
deodorant but body wash
bar soap toothpaste shampoo conditioner
and sunscreen i love the bar soap from
native that's one of my favorite
products they make
and this year
up your personal hygiene routine with
native go to nativedio.com
tuesday or use promo code tuesday at
checkout and get 20 off your first order
that's native deo.com
tuesday or use promo code tuesday at
checkout for 20 off your first order you
will love native their products are
so high quality i'm so excited about
today's sponsor emmy
emmy is the world's first low carb high
protein and 100 plant-based instant
ramen it's non-gmo and is 35 lower in
sodium versus traditional brands so if
you like ramen and you want to eat ramen
but also feel good about yourself
emmy is going to change your life it is
low carb with only six grams of net
carbs per serving emmy makes it easy to
reach your health goals and it's high
protein which is super important for me
it's 21 grams of protein each serving of
emmy helps you stay full longer
their nutrition packed ramen has up to
35 percent less sodium than the
competitors and it leaves you full and
satisfied without the post-ramen
bloating and thirst emmy is 100
plant-based and dairy-free and it's also
really good for your digestive health
with 18 grams of fiber which is up to
four times
more fiber than other instant ramen
brands
it's convenient
to prepare you can do it in the
microwave or the stove top you can have
a bowl ready in seven minutes
they are available in delicious and
comforting crafted plant-based flavors
with spicy beef ramen tom yum shrimp
ramen black garlic chicken ramen and
they use high quality ingredients
for the noodle and soup base with no
unnatural preservatives yummy is up to
85 percent lower in net carbs than other
instant ramen brands it contains up to
three times more protein than other
instant ramen brands and it contains
four times more fiber as well
so you guys can click our link below and
use our code tuesday at checkout or go
to emmyeats.com
tuesday for five dollars off your order
that's emmyeats.com tuesday or just
click the link below and use our code
tuesday for five dollars off a variety
pack today
me is also proud to offer a hundred
percent happiness guarantee so you can
try me risk free and decide for yourself
if emmy is worth it if you're not happy
with your emmy they will offer you a
full refund within 30 days of purchase
so the last nine years have sort of just
been a mirage but what's so cool about
what we're saying before about how
everyone we looked up to everything that
we were like aspiring to do doesn't
really exist anymore there are no and we
all have our own networks of people and
kind of we're just collecting the people
that jive with us and i think because
hollywood was so kind of like this it
was like hollywood had to accept you and
take you in and now it's not that
anymore it's like it's us it's up to you
putting out what we do and whoever
sticks to it sticks to it if they don't
we don't ever need to even worry about
it yeah we're all kind of these like
little islands that it's like if you
find us you get us but like
you know no one can be forced on you
anymore you know and no one is is going
to watch a show they don't like you have
to like actively fight to find the
person you're a fan of yeah you know so
it's like a lot of
you know that's a very different you
know thing because then you got to go
okay who am i like what do i want to do
when i'm not like i'm trying to appeal
to this or i'm i'm on nbc at five
o'clock on fridays i know what that demo
wants or i'm doing stand up for i can
it's hard to read a room when you don't
know who's in the room and that's what
where i get lost in pogba you sound like
you like a very specific assignment
i like to know the assignment yeah
you sound like you're about to give
around
i'm so i'm my assignment for you is that
we do go camping but we go to an
unfamiliar place like patagonia the
elementary store and stuff i know i was
like george is wearing a great patagonia
shirt right now we went to the south of
south america i didn't know that's a
real thriller we throw ourselves against
the elements like i i i'm at that point
and whitney listen we'll film it
okay as long as there is a drone
involved
is the hair and makeup team
in patagonia
what if we hired you a pet um drone that
followed you all the time and then you
didn't have to do anything can it be a
rescue drone
so as long as it was someone else's
drone that was mistreating it
like someone else not you
yeah i think it's like i think what like
isn't it kind of wild like that our
personal life and our professional life
all of a sudden just became the same
life yeah are you a little
discombobulated i think so this can
bobby laden
i think so but i'm a little different
from you guys where you guys are really
in the front of it all like i i get to
just podcast and stay here so i don't
get i don't have to go up in front of
crowds i don't have to do meet and
greets like you guys are on a different
like level that's my favorite we don't
have to suck bobby's dick that is true
he's very healthy i think we don't have
to get on all fours and pretend we're
like a woodworker from the 1920s or
whatever you do because it's like you
look at the like you the people that are
really like
killing it this right they have a
partner that's doing it with them you
know what i mean if it's like tom and
christina or like bert's got his you
know burton leanne and you and bobby and
you and like do you need to have a
partner in all of that like can you have
a personal life and then also be a
podcast i think you just have to be open
for all the things that you want but i
will say this whitney i throw so much
like on tiger belly sex talk every all
of that stuff is very disposable
material for me but i in my heart of
hearts i've never exposed anything from
here like the the sex talk and the
physical things that are obvious i'm
okay with but how i truly feel about my
life i'll never talk about i'll never
talk about it and i feel like i've done
i've honored myself in that that's for
consumption it's like you know like how
do we
have private lives so we can continue to
be interesting in our public lives like
i feel like i'm like at a little bit of
a breaking point i had a friend who was
like she was like saying that she was
she was like i really want to meet theo
where can i'm like when did you meet you
haven't met him before she's like we're
connected i'm like how do you know and
she's like i listened to his podcast and
i was like i don't like you anything
that's dangerous parasol i really like
it i feel in a i feel like i don't trust
you as a like you don't fully know this
person you have no clue and i'm telling
you i know the two of you and there's
nothing interesting there's no there's
nothing but i think a lot of what we do
is the intersection of
what we offer and then what they project
like and and the thing is somewhere in
between you know what i mean and it's
like you know we also think we have
these connections with our fans that
they're probably like [ __ ] i don't know
you like i
can i get a photo i'm like sure and then
i'm like hey so what are you doing oh
like that's what i'm doing i'm telling
you my meet and greet the i'm the only
one the fans are ending it they're like
we gotta go
i'm the one in the parasocial
relationship with my fans i think we're
really close because i've shared all
this stuff with you and i've put all
this work into this and they're like
yeah no i don't listen to podcasts i
just like your stand up and i'm like oh
what like what's the best when you're
like you're almost taking the compliment
when there's a meet and greet you're
like oh my god your big fan like oh i
never knew who you were until tonight
and then i i totally think that i'm like
uh cured your mom's cancer yeah it's you
know it's very confusing because some
people have this really intense
connection to you some people are like
yeah i saw you on instagram once you
were funny and i thought i'd come to a
show and it's like it's everyone that
comes up is everyone has a different
experience with you and we have to be
able to like in an instant change the
way we attune to them
yeah i smother
fans all the time no we see people that
come to show their their heads are in
your tits every day yeah and they're
just like hi
they're like we thought this was a joan
rivers like a 3d interactive they're
like six feet
your tips aren't that big [ __ ] you
gotta get some new ones
you know what i'm saying like we thought
you were chelsea handler we
and i'm like
you're welcome what could i'll make a
video do you want to make a video for
your daughter i mean i've it's so funny
because i
there isn't i i feel like as comedians
though there is this thing that's
happening that i feel like we have to
push back on of like how we're like
heroes all of a sudden and it's like i i
think being people's hero is like
it's just it's never gonna go well it
doesn't go well it's not sustainable
i had this girl
come up at a meet and greet and she
holds up her phone and she goes
she goes my sister died
a year ago can you make her a video
oh
okay benton's next to me rosebud baker's
next to benton another comedian and i'm
like huh like i can't even hear her
there's like you are kelly's playing i
mean truly ignition by r kelly is
playing because i have a joke about that
song so we play it at the end
so liz rapist song is playing she's
talking about her dead sister and i
can't hear her
um and then she gives me her phone to
make a video for her sister
and it's a snapchat video okay because a
lot of the meet and greets people want
to do a snapchat and then i guess save
it or post it gives it to me
i hold it up to my face to go like okay
what do you want me to say exactly i
tried to get really serious and really
respectful of this girl who had lost her
sister and she's like can you please say
rest in paradise margaret rest in
paradise got okay got it and i'm like
really trying to be sincere and be like
i need to like help this girl
and um i pulled the snapchat and i have
[ __ ]
like babyface with freckles on a
snapchat
and i'm like okay now
you need to wait you need to wish my
dead sister well but you need to be
younger why are you oh yeah you kind of
ished out of this but also yeah like i
don't
if i do like did you pick this filter
for me like do i have to change it like
it was this really intense moment where
i was like i'm just not equipped for
this moment and then you're like and did
you want to pay cash or card
technologically emotionally otherwise so
then i'm like and then i'm like okay
this is like the baby cutesy filter i
have to change the filter this is like a
a rest in peace video
for this girl who's grieving and then i
start switching it and then i like i
have like dog ears i have cat and then i
have like a like a skeleton face and
like i'm like that was just the right
one was it yeah that was it i can't find
a filter
i can't find a filter that works for her
dead sister and then and then benton
who's on the podcast with me looks over
and
obviously doesn't understand the
situation is emotional because i'm on
snapchat looking at filters yes from his
perception so he's just like what are
you doing bash but he's like what are
you dead [ __ ] no it's like hey sister
you really and that's exactly what
happened so and then i go i go oh i'm
just making a little video for um
for uh
for this girl's sister and men just goes
what is she dead
and i was like she did die a year ago uh
and this girl's crying and i'm like
she's crying she's bawling crying like
can you make a video for my dead sister
and i'm like
i didn't sign up for this also is she
dying or dead because where's the video
getting so confused my career is dying
right here right now
who's making that video so i was like i
would have used a voice disorder what
that's the filter you know the filters
with a voice distorter
i was just like i didn't sign up to like
like console people that were grieving
like i didn't know that's why you need
the person you need benton or one of
your assistants to or executive
producers of your life
to
to go
we have to keep move on sorry next but
it's so awkward no it's very awkward but
you have to have someone else do it
because we do want to connect with them
and then it's like 12 hours like how my
meeting roots go along
i want to connect with everyone i want
to deliver i want to facetime your
friend i want to facetime i'll facetime
you guys because people come up to me in
your merch or like they'll be like when
are you doing trash tuesday and i'll be
like i'll just like facetime you guys at
my meet and greet so they can see i'll
do whatever i can
but like i'm like oh my god do we
accidentally [ __ ] up and become we can
anything we do we can always be
something else i'll say this i don't
think any fans of this show think any of
the three of us are heroes so i think
that's more of a you it's
problem because let me tell you
something my favorite demographic or my
favorite kind my favorite dms are from
um inmates
they are sweetie pies
they say some real sweet [ __ ] from jail
[ __ ] too we like that yeah and they're
like boy that's been bent over i know
and um i don't know if you i think that
you know these guys
i don't know what your thoughts are on
pen pals in prison but i think that
we're overlooking these guys i think so
too
uh what do you think as long as they
don't get out though they don't
conjugals
whoever does not
sit in a pen pal i just want to make
that clear are you interested in the
conjugal visit then without in prison
where is the local women's prison
where is gizlane going to jail would you
know that i can't wait that's the big
question
i'm interested in you kiss lane what are
the chances that um you would partake in
a lesbian affair with esther whoa whoa i
didn't whisper that
can i just oh this is a game of
telephone i may have
i guess like i don't i see esther is
like my like um
yeah it's just like my nephew
like i don't i but but it
always
always surprises me how hot you are
every time i see you
on instagram it's not shocking it just i
for
your person like you just work so hard
to not
seem hot because
i'm annoying as [ __ ] no just like when i
you're just so it's just interest it's
just interesting how hot you are i think
she's talked to dick out of her mouth
once or twice
because you you know what it is this is
it no no you're it's subterfuge you hide
your hotness
and then you show it on social media
sometimes or like in person every now
and then we'll catch a glimpse of it
because you are like um you know have
you seen big trouble in little china do
you remember the ball from big trouble
in little china you know you guys don't
know this movie i do know the movie but
i haven't watched it she basically is
just the ball from big trouble like
she's just a ball of sweatpants and like
flannels but then she's like and you
just see everybody yes
and then you see her like in a bra and
you're like jesus you're
gorgeous like like you're toxically
gorgeous like but also young looking so
it's weird i know
i can't i i'm so pale i do have a
question though like are you
like a are you like a horny [ __ ]
i'm definitely a horny [ __ ]
uh because i've seen your your house
like i've gone through your things
and you have like a lot of like sexy
stuff i know i know this is the thing
that i thought you know my new obsession
is the things i thought i was getting
away with
and you're like like i had this
realization last night that was like
you're not getting away with anything
[ __ ] like
have you ever called yourself out on
being like you thought no one's noticed
that and everyone did like that like
like how you've played yourself yeah i
have
like in my home i do have a couple
drawers of like
and like corsets and like crazy [ __ ] and
like a couple like and i and then i had
friends over during the pandemic for
like a year oh it was so fun oh my god
her vagina and [ __ ] are out so fast
whitney you like that's like your
doorbell is your [ __ ]
to get in
i do have a deflated hemorrhoid right
under my [ __ ] that i'm really
insecure but i feel like most people
have internal hemorrhoids you know what
but this one is an external one that
came from that remember when everyone
was doing for exercise it was something
called bar method it was like isometrics
and every girl was getting and from soul
cycle spinning everyone was getting a
hemorrhoid from the same time
you can get a hemorrhoid i'm like
300 rides deep in a cycle yeah i've yet
to see a cherry yeah well let me tell
you something uh the best thing to do is
to get your hemorrhoids rubber banded
hemorrhoidectomy is that what it is that
what it's called can a vet do that and
am i allowed to ask
you can ask my ex-boyfriend vet for
whatever drugs and hemorrhoid rubber
bands you need did you ever role play
when you were dating a younger guy i
when i play i can't i it makes me laugh
too hard yeah it's ridiculous it's too
silly she acts for her job like
it's not i can role play like
quiet i can role play
like
silly i can role play
like this i don't want this i can't role
play like a lawyer like hi
i can't role play like yeah i'm here to
check your account yeah yeah i can't
role play like so class has
begun
you guys i can't believe we have
athletic greens as a sponsor
i
love them some days i just don't have
the time
to
think about
my daily greens intake how much vitamins
and minerals i'm supposed to be
taking daily and athletic greens just
eliminates all of that stress i simply
open my packet i added an eight ounce
eight ounces of cold water and ta-da i
have my body has what it needs what i
love about it is that it doesn't taste
super healthy um it actually has a
really mild tropical taste that i look
forward to each morning
with one delicious scoop of athletic
greens you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole food source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help you start your day right this
special blend of ingredients supports
your gut health your nervous system your
immune system your energy recovery focus
and aging
you guys right now it's time to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition
especially heading into cold and flu
season it's just one scoop in a cup of
water every day and that's it and
there's no need for a million different
pills and supplements to look out for
your health and to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free one
year supply of immune supporting vitamin
d and five free travel packs which we
have here i brought with me um with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com tuesday again
that is
athleticgreens.com to take ownership of
your health and pick up the ultimate
daily nutritional insurance
so
as you guys know i'm obsessed with and
in love with magic spoon i had it for
dinner
three times this week i had a bowl of
the fruity magic spoon with some almond
milk it's so good i eat it late at night
when i'm craving i like have that
craving but don't want to feel bad about
what i'm doing it's keto friendly gluten
free grain freeze toy free and low carb
low carb cereal
it's a miracle magic spoon has zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
and only four net grams of carbs in each
serving and only 140 calories serving
like i feel good about myself
they have um
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry cinnamon cookies and cream and
maple waffle i love the frosted you can
actually create your own bundle
and pick out which ones you want i like
to get the frosted um with everything
did you know that frosted peanut butter
tastes good
i didn't know until i tried to either
you guys can go to magicspoon.com
tuesday to grab a custom bundle of
cereal and start your new year off right
and be sure to use our promo code
tuesday at checkout to save five dollars
off your order remember get your next
delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com tuesday and use the code
tuesday to save five dollars off thank
you magic spoon for sponsoring this
episode
when i was in college i hooked up with
this guy that was like a freshman when i
was a senior for the third time and he
had a micro penis no shame guys it's
just i love a good mic it happens but he
was like and it was the first and it was
the last time well i had [ __ ] him
several times but um he so it was like
suctiony there was no i felt no
penetration and he was going like he
looked up to me because i was like you
know the older like hot girl at his
college he was like i can't believe i'm
[ __ ] annie letterman i was like
neither can i um i don't know that you
are sir but thank you for pronouncing it
correctly i know he didn't say leader
man
that is that's intense i was like micro
that's intense no but so okay so role
play okay look my deal with sex
i think i'm pretty good at it i know my
strengths i know where i am oh my god i
don't know why i imagined you actually
like lifting them
i know my strengths they're maybe a
little bit traditional but where do you
shine i really shine underneath [ __ ]
are really where i shine okay is the
word on the street also her forehead and
the rest of her face wait we have to ask
her the question we're anti-blow jobs
we're pro
[ __ ]
oh i'm so pro facebook oh thank god oh
i'm super i'm pro face [ __ ]
although recently i was face [ __ ] in
uh lying on my back and then
then she bagged no i'm uh
backwards spiderman
yeah like off the bed like neck off the
bed this direction you got tonsils
removed i just i had a like a crick in
my neck the next day it was just like a
little like i had to hold it was
fine i know facebook me you also have to
pay for the like
chiropractor yeah i just need like a
like a like a um call them my pillow guy
i just need like a little
yeah
it was just like i wasn't i am down for
like literally whatever like i have no
like sexual like i don't do that i don't
do that the role play thing i just i
just can't keep a straight face i i've
tried i uh
i i'm fun
i'm [ __ ] fun i told a guy yeah you
can pee on me pee on me go for it
in the shower well this was a while back
in the sh we did like did it in the
shower on my face yeah looking up
burst out laughing oh the people could
not did you snored a little piss in
there i was laughing he's laughing like
i had to leave and like walk take a walk
like i was had to give there's something
about getting peed on that like it loses
its magic when it's in the shower i i
felt like it was because we're always
getting peed on the shower i just
thought yeah i thought like getting peed
on because there was a guy i was going
to
let pee on me and then we just stopped
liking each other so we just never did
it's the cleanup that's yeah yeah you
have to consider if this is your fetish
have your life i think the shower's hot
because you can do it right in the face
no problem
yeah because like the worst thing is
like if a guy degrades you in some way
well i think the only thing about that i
don't like
sexually is when someone either
has anal sex with you
and then right afterwards like goes in
the shower and it's like yeah like or
pees on you and that was like won't kiss
you or touch you and you're like well
now i just feel like an idiot totally
you know what i'm saying you have to
like be responsible for the damage you
cause like you have to be like on board
like anal sex and peeing on just do it
in the shower so there's no awkwardness
we're just peeing our butts pee in our
bodies no no no no
it cures hemorrhoids
so it's like so i just i like to kind of
like get ahead of those embarrassing
moments where afterwards you're like oh
that was like super fun but now
like we can't make eye contact yeah
because the only point for me to even be
degraded in the first place
is the treatment afterwards like there's
a reward at the end of that rainbow yeah
like for me it's the fact that the the
the tlc that i get the stroking he puts
conditioner in my hair he scrubs me down
after peeing in my face it's that overt
um
affection afterwards that i am really
doing everything for
it's like this bobby can reach your hair
but wait hold on see that's it that's
interesting i
i'm in it for the being
degraded the afterwards i don't need you
to make up for that's the way that's the
score like i think
i'm into it like i i'll totally say it
like the degrading part is the cuddling
and the hair conditioning i'm
because i think on some level i guess
what's hot about it is like i know that
on some carnal level
he feels
like it's hot to him and it's hot to me
and like the score is settled
you know what i'm saying
like
you're preaching to the choir because i
know who i am in my real life and i know
that i'm i you know so kalila was just
pretending she likes the aftercare but
she actually i don't i will after my own
i pay someone to wash my hair i don't
need my the guy i have sex with to do it
oh my god give me their number but like
i think i think for me like it's weird
as i get older like i am
being degraded is just my [ __ ] i don't
know it makes me respect the guy
if the guy tries to take care of me i
just i'm like i can take care of myself
i don't need if i'm if i'm like in love
with the person though it does bother me
so it's like i've had like i like when
it's just like a casual thing a guy can
[ __ ] do really well and i prefer that
yeah because it's like less intimate or
something interesting but then if i like
i had a boyfriend who
the first time we [ __ ]
like and we had a very loving friendship
and stuff too before the first time we
[ __ ] he was like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i was like no not i know it
was just so like that's a bummer i was
like you gotta work up just like yeah
you were just like it was just like so
surprising it was too much of a chef i
definitely would not want to be in like
a casual one-off thing where someone
does that stuff to me i feel like you
have to like do it
yes yes yes safety and love i don't feel
that way i feel the exact opposite i'm
like i had a guy like spitting in my
mouth and then he was trying to date me
afterwards i'm like i'm not meeting your
mother after you spit in my mouth it's
if you know someone respects you already
and you're already that's when you can
do [ __ ] anything and have the best
time so i am molested in a different way
than you are because i feel the opposite
like i can be more like i don't know
it's like
i like i think it's because it's it's
les it just it distances me from them as
much of the like the role playing if i
would do more would probably would like
andy and i have different methods for
reclaiming our rapes
i guess like for me i'm seeking a new
rape
i'm like you know virus chasers yes
whitney so because i was raped and
diddled way too many times when i was
younger
i needed someone to just
rape me from beginning to end without
like i gave someone permission to say to
basically
have me walk through the door unprepared
and just fully rape me someone that i
trusted obviously
and it made me feel so much better and
we're going to reveal who that person
was it was me
and we've been so much she would never
have allowed she would never have
allowed you to do that but would you be
okay with that have you done that where
you're like okay here just completely
just
go off
uh okay so
i'm gonna i'm i'm sorry about what
happened to you
i just want to it's just tricky to just
blow past all that that's what our
product does
i'm like why is it so easy for me and
annie
i just was gonna go you gave someone
permission to rape you whenever they
were like that yeah like you have to
like i know that's the thing that's the
trickiest part about like fantasies is
like how do you let them know that you
want it without consenting yeah yeah
yeah
you gotta give them a little bit it's
like you can't rape it
it's a great fact you have to come who
better not rape me it's like yeah i'm
like can you rape me like just never
don't tell me what you're gonna do
exactly no i honestly have a guy friend
who's a comic book i'll tell you guys
afterwards who it is who he's in such a
dangerous territory because he was
telling me he has this girl that was
like i want you to like break into my
house and rape me at some point and so
he's been doing this with her but he'll
like have to wait till random night that
is literally the scariest thing but i
guess i can understand the fetish of
this girl because it's so [ __ ] scary
that she's definitely but the wording's
off this is a communication breakdown
i want you to break in
fake break in right and fake rape me but
that's what she's asking yeah but she
doesn't give him like she gives him like
a month of doing surprisingly but it is
me but make sure
i've showered make sure i know i didn't
just eat lasagna
[Applause]
you have to make sure you know what
you're actually asking yeah because it's
so true the lasagna bit especially it's
not gonna go the way you think it's
going to go
if i'm having a fully private fart party
by myself do not break in
and directly i thought you weren't
giving your heart in this podcast
that's what i'm saying is like can you
just like break in and rape me don't
tell me when and then it's like you know
i'm like just about to win on fruit
ninja like not now
not now is that what you call
masturbating
i just want fruit ninjas let's do a
banana break as we continue this
conversation
[Music]
did you finish that that fast that was a
nuance i think when you said during the
rape talk whitney just literally deep
throated banana and one never seen it
this is literally esther as a banana i
got the smallest banana you guys have
and it's also overly ripe it's pudding
it wasn't that hard to chew
yeah these bananas have been sitting
around since [ __ ] treasure patus was
here so i would just calm down
i will say something that if we are the
ones that like to be face [ __ ] and
what news the one that likes to suck
dick i think you've
you've proven it
like it's not that hard to eat a banana
you all are a little rusty because
they're just sucking up dicks but it's
not that hard
we all have tmj so the dick sucking is i
literally had a doctor once almost write
me a note for it
it's because none of you and all y'all
have fake nails and you can't peel [ __ ]
wait i'm glad you said that when you
because do you want to know what i had
to do yesterday you guys i was late for
an appointment
and i had street parking i literally had
to have a stranger on the street put my
car in and out of the thing because i my
nails i couldn't get the credit card out
of the i've had that issue it's so
embarrassing yeah how do you suck dick
how do you can suck dick with those
nails why not really yeah what are you
doing with your nails that we can't i
just feel like you can't work that's why
you don't have to
you can't put your fingers up but
you have to put in you have to put well
this is why i only keep this one's not
an option is the opposite of a coke nail
so i keep all the other nails longer for
this because this goes up the bottom
oh the first finger yeah because i hold
from the back right so if he's jerking
off in front like this i hold him like
this and then i finger like this but you
oh i use my finger oh that's the longest
one but okay
where's his dick going opposite we're
not facing each other am i the only one
here
oh yeah
i need a fish
[Laughter]
like do you remember in charlie and
chocolate factory when the mom was
washing the laundry
in that big bin in a circle she's also
the blueberry girl is that like
depression era wait wait i've been
taking peptides and i want to show you
my ass it was that cut from kkk hoods
from the 20s i hate your underwear i
love your ass so much it's not getting
oh
your ass is wild i'm working out okay
here your ass is wild
in the shower oh my god she lifted you
oh
you're a man
i always thought of you as a lady
you're never a man you know what oh my
god
yeah you're like dominating well no
that's i just thought all dudes were
here's the thing
i'm she's a short guy so she can lift
you're so ready to be sexual with me
because you're used to bobby's body yeah
the way she lifted you she kind of went
like two she like did like
and she lifted there was a grunt test
with you so because i think in my brain
i learned like look i did read a book
that is very problematic that did
the marriage book yeah
which one
you ruined nikki's life too a nicki
blazer i know i i feel like i've had to
scream at both of you like the [ __ ] the
book she well she's like it saved my
life it changed my life now i'm i don't
know but basically the whole point of
the book getting to i do it was written
in like the 80s and they'll forget all
the like [ __ ] like it's so
corny and ridiculous but
the point is there has to be a masculine
and a feminine it doesn't matter who
that is and forget those triggering
words i know there's no such thing as
gender i got it there has to be a giver
and a receiver put that the woman can be
the receiver the man can be the giver or
vice versa the man can be the feminine
the woman you know can be the masculine
it doesn't matter but you do have to
pick at some point and so for me my
brain was just like oh i can't go back
and forth from being like oh my god no
thank you dude like i'm gonna
finger your ass yeah
i do want to say that getting to
identity pick one and kalila that move
that you just said was getting to the
pooh
like i just do we like can you go back
and forth i think so yes um
you're not fluidity or am i like but in
a relationship with the same person how
do you know when it's like okay now i'm
going to be the dominant one or now i'm
going to be the literature i guess i
guess the only problem i have with that
type of book and stuff is that you now
have this idea in your head that you're
now taking yourself out of the moment
with this person which like
vulnerability just you have to be
present yeah i will say this
is overrated what is the moment okay
lexapro
that idea might actually apply to me
because i've never felt so
like
full of
again without using the trigger words
but like i i do feel very masculine
around bobby when it comes to sex we all
do
but in a way that is like i think that
because you're with someone that i think
and correct me if i'm wrong or
overstepping like had some sexual trauma
so did you i think having someone come
in and just like handle it and not leave
them to their own devices and just be
like i got you yeah i'm not you know
what i mean
and then
him so that he doesn't have to feel
shame like you're right i'm gonna get
ahead of this shame like this is okay
like but i'm not getting ahead of my own
needs because i do
i think that's why
i
feel a little bit sometimes like i
really [ __ ] myself because i'm
somebody that wants to be
you know
i want to be i want to receive it's
tricky because it's tricky because
and this is um someone who is not on
edibles but it's going to sound like it
which is like when you do stuff like
that you're being of service to him
which is actually the feminine right you
know what i'm saying even though it
ostensibly seems masculine when you're
like i'm on my knees fingering you so
that you can come like that is actually
like traditionally feminine yeah even
though it's like i have a question
colliding with
that move on other guys before bobby
do you tell them or do you just oh no i
tell them all the time because you have
to ask like are you kissing and then all
of a sudden you're like
uh
can you grab my phone and they like turn
around and then you're just lifting them
real real question though real question
because i think a lot of people i have
this question actually
when you finger a butthole yeah for a
man
it's not the idea is not to go as high
up as possible isn't it to go up and
forward and forward to push
push the prostate so you pull up
and
towards you you're not getting a
surprise
you push
no i am
how do i get to your granny panties
how do your underwear match your name
i think that i don't i'm only you know
that right maybe the the men i've been
with but you're not fingering like you
would have put you put you put it in a
little bit to the butthole and then you
push towards not the absolute towards
the dick can i share hot goss hot tea
i'm wearing white underwear white full
butt panties and white jeans are the
number one thing i think guys are into
like like like well i hope they're into
the period stain i'm not saying they're
like
like that's like i think kind of like a
known thing that's like oh yeah like
white panties that say like the day of
the week well because it's like virginia
it's virginal yeah
it says one day of the week
i have like a couple pairs of policies
that are full but like that say like
calvin klein that look like yeah
yeah not kids don't do that
no
not kids i'm 39. i but i do know like
there is a basic carnal
like thing wrong i'll be like okay well
tonight i'm busting out just like the
virginal white mad january jones and mad
men like full-butted thing that feels
very like innocent like virgin suicides
kind of thing it's like you're saying
it's like a look yeah it's like i i
actively know that you are into this i
have a theory about that i feel like
certain people with certain like very
structured jawlines like myself could
never look that virginal so it doesn't
matter if you throw me in the fullest
butted panty on earth but you're by the
way your face isn't involved your face
is agreeing with you and i think the
same works reversed for me like i can be
like the little like school girl but i
can't pull off like some like sexy
goddess it's just no you know what it is
it's like i think it's like so
surprising on you that it's a lot it's
no i think it's i think that i think the
hottest thing with any kind of like sexy
lingerie or anything is you coming out
being like i don't even know if this is
how it's supposed to work yeah it's like
backwards they don't work
out cause you have a song
oh my god i don't want you like
here's my costume like it's like
this we're the sexiest thing that you
can find from china on amazon
and then you're coming out and you're
like is this how it's the effort behind
it and the fact that you're trying so
hard for them that they're into but
you're like you don't have to like stick
the landing you don't have to book the
audition you're like you don't have to
get you could only think about it
this is like she's going executive
producer again he's saying it's gonna
stay on your body for another 20 seconds
it's just about the effort of like is
this what you want and then i like shy
that's what they like like i've never i
mean i you i have literally top giant
tupperware bins of lingerie
that i bought worn maybe once don't know
how like i mean god like when you go in
the bathroom and you're putting on the
freaking pantyhose that go into the clip
of the the things
and doing all the things and it's like
yeah it takes more time to put on than
take off he doesn't care nobody cares
like the best it doesn't matter if
you're selling it or
it looks good on you you walk out and
you're like is this how i'm supposed to
wear this fog like and he's like
and then he'll do the rest and then you
just i just come in fully duct taped i'm
like yeah
wait okay question because we have a lot
of male slugs male listeners like if you
guys look slugs slugs what we call our
fans thanks for watching the show oh
cute but um i think guys or girls god
please comment like what is who's right
like what is well i have a lot of
questions about this dom sub thing yeah
i did have a guide like try to fully do
a dom sub thing with your cracking up
and i
well i'm like working on this whole new
bit about it because it's all i can it's
all i can talk about i think about
because
i i might be
it's a real thing
okay where it's like the guy's like i'm
the dumb you're the sub
and i'm gonna tell you what to eat and
you don't
i dare todd i dare you todd but he's to
try that
but it's i'm like
i'm into it let's try this
it's just
i have i might be either too literal
or the logistics are just wonky what
happened
well it was just like
so exciting this is fun let's yes let's
totally do this and then uh it was like
it's it's very awkward at the beginning
because i've never done anything like
that before like i don't i don't know
what that means and uh so i'm like
what should i eat today and he's like a
bowl of spaghetti for lunch and i'm like
that's gonna come out my [ __ ] but
then no that's the thing and then i'm
like
so i have to make it do i wanna i have a
gluten intolerance
i have a lot of questions it's like now
i'm doing dishes now like this really is
sadistic
but then it's like don't look at me in
the eye during sex it's like
all the rules were things i wasn't doing
anyway yeah that's like don't look at me
during sex it's like i got this i think
i i think i can dump myself yeah i know
it's like you mean like not play
peek-a-boo during sex like i normally do
like hey
[Laughter]
the hardest thing for me during like a
dom sub thing is for me not to like feel
the need to retaliate if there's some
real domination and either or my command
or something like i want i slap if you
pinch me or slap no well here's the
thing like honestly like i've been
slapped before and in my head i'm like
[ __ ] like cause you didn't do anything
and for me not to say that out loud yeah
interesting yeah so would be like well
you gotta you'd be like [ __ ] i mean my
[ __ ] i don't understand why can't it be
like a battle like why can't it be like
me
like like you said he hits you it's hard
enough and you're like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and like why can't you but that's not
dom sub anymore that's hot though that's
just a dumb dumb but it doesn't have to
be like that that's a conversation but
can i answer a question yeah is is our
dom i i don't know much about this
community at all i know it's like a real
thi is a dom a dom in every relationship
i'm not sure i think it's just sort of
this like mutual contract you maybe come
up with i think it should be weak you
you is it constant that's all their days
off like i just it feels very like not
sustainable
after a while you know what i mean like
i think that that's where i get confused
that's why i think these things are like
the it's like you have the rules and
then you like interpret them yourself
like the bible we do that with the bible
i also just think this is it's very
similar to the bible thank you so much
for me it is but i don't know how
long it can go on do you know what i
mean yeah um and all this talk really
the best thing
for me still is a boring missionary yeah
yeah it's true that that is like that is
the kinkiest thing you can do at this
point really yeah on top like just very
normal wonder none of this should be
waterproof
yeah yeah have you ever had sex on a um
yoga ball
no
that sounds fine okay it's a little
bouncy so yeah so that's like a rich
hollywood always the multitaskers own
one so no so i i was dating someone that
was like working from home and i work
out from home and uh
porn now it's a lot of gym porn like i i
do deep dives into porn you prefer jim
from the office
everyone's looking at camera
they break the fourth wall
and uh there's a lot of like like yoga
ball i was just and having sex on a yoga
ball is very
fun well you have to have poor strength
the guy has to be in really good shape
if he's on top because because you can
kind of like i don't know there's a that
you can like move your hips in a way or
like the ball helps you
do
the movement yeah i can't explain it
velocity
and working out i've been doing um like
where you have to balance on the ball
yeah and so i was just for some reason i
was imagining you starting in doggy
and he's banging you and you have to
stay in your core strength and then you
you like stand up like this and then
he's [ __ ] you from behind that's just
really hard because if i can't fully
relax my body there's just no way i'm
going to come so if there's any type of
like
effort
yeah yeah it's probably not where you're
gonna have an orgasm necessarily but
you're you're like oh whoa this is like
wait i know what it is the ball is doing
the work for you
i think that's why there's something you
don't have to do it's like what i lost
my friend on water bed and i was like
that's like such a lazy move
yeah like it's like the guy has to be in
really good shape because i the feedback
from the guy was like that was really
difficult
and you're like
that was amazing he was like that was
incredibly difficult
so i think it was really hard for him
sounds like this is something i'll never
be able but also like it it catches the
rhythm for you too you don't have to it
was just like it was just fun i don't
know i think it was just fun maybe you
know and then also there's a
uh i've never i don't have a sex bench
or anything but i've heard of them but
there's a like you know the thing you
lift the weights on where you're like
yeah like you're half lean back that's
also like a new twist on missionary i
never thought of before of being like
more
angled up angled off yeah like at like
like 40 degrees up whitney i told you
how todd and i [ __ ] right i have like
the
little bag
once a week i think you're right at the
bottom i just present my videos i cannot
get enough of it it's changed my life
it's ruined our friendship i think about
it too much toxic amount
um but uh
yeah i don't know it's it's i yeah i'm
i'm a big missionary person and i think
the most dumb hot [ __ ] you can do is
just like have the guy just like go
[ __ ] you yeah i think we should call
this the bible study and we're
missionaries
yeah maybe that's it you guys i have to
run i have to go do a thing that cost me
money so i can't quit yeah all right
love you guys i love you have a safe
trip
winnie i have a question for you uh oh
wow that was abrupt since you're really
into
you're the
neuroscience queen what are your
thoughts on
bacteria choosing our partners for us
that's a big one isn't it
i'm really really starting to
buy into this idea a thousand percent it
is the problem is once you start getting
into this
you're in a rabbit hole
that
eventually spirals into
we're all just trash bags full of blood
that's the only problem so it's like
once you start going okay
if you smell bad to me you know that
means on some level we could be related
that's nature's way of you know look
there's dr andrew huberman talks about
this a lot uh uh luanne brisendine talks
about this a lot i'm uh
look i i'm a scientist um
whitney rogan hoe rogan is what they
call me
but apparently our olfactory glands the
way that we smell
uh essentially dictates who we're
attracted to you know so
it's like the same thing with the robot
like it's like everyone's you know so
freaked out that i made this robot for
my last special
and
the way that people are like
freak out when they see a robot that's
something called pathogen avoidance
which is the biological basis for people
being grossed out by robots is that they
uh it's nature's way of making us not
[ __ ] something that
is sick or dead
so anything that looks human
but doesn't move like a human that could
be something that's sick or dead so the
people that
did that that were
those were the people that survived so
it the more grossed out by a sex robot
or sex doll you are the more your
ancestors [ __ ]
corpses oh it's necrophilia
so so is it bad if i'm just like that's
cool
similarly like with this it's like you
know when we when something smells bad
that means stay away from it right you
know that's nature's way of saying bad
no good and usually it's incest you know
so do you think people actually have bad
breath or do you think our bacterias are
just not matching
blowing because i have
had like i had a friend in high school
who i thought had halitosis say for
instance
but her man was all up in there like
nothing and i was like oh we're just not
like nature doesn't want us to mate
right but okay i have a question though
do you think do you guys think it's what
comes first like is it possible that you
just are attract you you like the smell
of someone's breath just because you
like them or is it that you like
them
no i have an answer to this already i
know what you're saying because i have
fallen in love with somebody before even
getting intimate say for instance
and for some reason my ph is just
completely thrown off every time we have
sex and it's just not working out and
it's nothing that they i mean it's not
like they have you know crotch rod or
anything like that
i
hate that word
i don't even know what it is i don't
either but i know our parents used it
right
what is it
okay i am i am literally
the person that's like
pushes back on you can't say this that
word is the only word i i will not
tolerate
but um yeah there have been and and i
was really bummed out about it because
i'm like i can no longer have sex with
this person there is something about
their
makeup that is just not vibing but did
you still like it and want it yeah no
longer i just did not want to have sex
anymore the the there was no i had a
price to pay every time um and so
do you know what's really like blowing
my mind to think about is like what if
like
there was some kind of law that outlawed
like perfume
i would be so happy so that we would
actually stop because that's such a
manipulation we find our soul mates much
faster don't you think like i feel like
we and well birth control also changes
the way
men smell to us so they say that if
you're on birth control if you get
engaged or something you should go off
birth control wait a year and make sure
you're still as attracted to that person
because when you're on birth control it
tells your body that you are pregnant
right so your olfactory glands start
finding different kinds of men
attractive when you're pregnant
obviously right
it's
i mean this is going to sound archaic
but like the more um
beta type of man is more attractive to
you when you're pregnant whereas the
more alpha type of man it because that's
the kind of man you want to
to get you pregnant not the kind of man
you want to care take your baby thank
you so what are you supposed to have
convinced your uh body that you're
having
so if you're on birth control and you're
attracted to somebody and you get
engaged go off it
stay with them for a year and just make
sure you're still as attracted to that
off birth control as you are on are we
are you it sounds like you're
prescribing us to like
get [ __ ] by an alpha and then tell the
beta it's his baby
[Laughter]
i'm just telling you human nature's a
[ __ ] nightmare and our bodies are
disgusting
um uh but
no but we don't choose what we find
attractive i don't think on the for the
most part you know we don't choose who
like makes our nipples hard when we
smell them you know it's so like
driven by all these carnal
forces and um
you know and also there's another
because the thing is with with smell is
there's also like have you ever like ran
into someone at a bar that was wearing
like ck one yes
just the nostalgia of like you smell
like
17 years ago like me sadie hawkins dance
curve like a man tommy hilfiger like
like it's just or some kind of where i'm
like i'm just in love with you because a
guy that i had a crush on
20 years ago who's probably in prison
now
like wore it
like and it i don't it reminds me of his
acne when we were slow dancing to hooty
and the blowfish like it doesn't it's so
irrational you know that um
i think to me i've i've been in so many
uh i've lost so much of my life to
being with people based on irrational
attractions that i i my fascination is
breaking down irrational attractions and
trying to make them rational
yeah the
i
i know exactly what you mean in the same
way that
my dreams get me in trouble in my real
life
like i think that
like there's some stand-up premise
like dreaming can really have like a
massive effect on my mental health that
week like sometimes i know like you know
sleep is restorative it's essential but
it can really throw me
off when i wake up
either depends on what happens in the
dreams if i've fallen in love with
someone else if i've fallen out of love
with somebody if i'm falling in love
with a [ __ ] stranger that i've never
met or if something yeah something just
and it lingers in my system as if it
really really really happened dude
you're a [ __ ] savage klyla like i i
i'm i've always every time i see you i'm
blown away by you i'm not i'm not even
joking and it's not even because you're
so pretty but like every time i see you
i'm like that [ __ ] is like on another
level like that blows my mind
that you said that not only that you
thought it but also that you admitted it
and then you were able to articulate it
but
dreams from what i understand
are to prepare us for scenarios that
could possibly happen right isn't that
the idea of why dreaming is so important
that we're actively engaged in our
dreams because it's how our psyche
prepares for the worst case scenario
so that we're prepared whoa yeah i can
see that especially with the reoccurring
dreams yeah everything's a survive
everything humans do is a survival
strategy like if we start looking it
through that lens that's when things
start to make sense to me at least when
it's like
while we're dreaming our body is
plotting planning how do we stay alive
how do we stay alive how do we survive
how do we survive right so that that i
from what i understand is what dreams
are is is
practice for the worst case scenario huh
whoa i wouldn't explain why i had sex
with a wild boar but
if that happened here's what we would do
here's how we or to like i think freud's
version was it's to purge things yes get
them out of our system and reinforce
reinforce the things that we need and
then dispose of the things we don't need
right like information we don't need
but um and some of it might just be wild
trash which is fine too you know but um
but i do think that like
like dreams from what i don't know i
worked with this
this emdr trauma therapist who was like
you have to be actively participating in
your dreams because
they're they're helping prepare you for
your worst fears and we can't figure out
where your worst fears are until we
understand what your dreams are i i
think this if there was a way for us to
actively lucid dream and participate i
think that might be a key to solving a
lot of mental illness because i've since
i was younger i have had moments of
lucid dreaming and they are very very
very it's a solve like it honestly feels
like i'm able to
tackle a problem i'm not really able to
tackle in real life and i wake up
feeling like restored like is this what
the metaverse is for
like is it
or if i have an itch to scratch i have a
crush on someone i'll have sex with him
and a lucid dream and that itch is
scratched and i will i wake up like
i've never had a lucid dream have you
you can practice your way into one by
accident i did it when i was younger and
i've been able to sort of
um not always but i i'm able to do it
once in a while is it just like you're
laying there and you're like fantasizing
about it no you're able to participate
in your dream knowing it's a dream
you're saying
i this is what's happening let's say
it's a burning house but you feel safe
in that burning house because you know
that it's only a dream
[Music]
that sounds so fun
a metaphor
but the problem is that when you are in
rem sleep your body operates like it is
like you know when you get it when you
when you
on your way to a restful sleep your
heart rate slows down your blood
pressure drops your brain waves are more
you know spaced right but when you get
into rem
your body thinks you're living that's
why there's
there's such a thing your body almost
forces itself into a paralysis so you
don't act out your dreams
because
your heart rate goes up your blood
pressure goes up you're actively living
there so for me the problem is when i
wake up and i've lived this thing
how it's how is it not how is it not
gonna affect me for the rest of the
[ __ ] week you can't shake it
just the craziest thing
after i had my boobs breast implants
my last special i explained why i got
them um and i got them late in life i
wasn't like trying to like get mad you
talk about it in your book yeah it's all
it's yeah i've explained it before i
don't want to be a broken record but um
i uh
after i got the breast implant surgery
you go under you're sedated
heavily
after that for like two weeks i was on
painkillers and then i started having
all these like suicidal thoughts never
in my life have had suicidal thoughts
that has never been a solution for me
never been something i thought was
interesting never been something i
condoned
and i like call this
emdr trauma therapist i'd worked with i
was like this has never happened before
but my brain is going like oh you should
be dead and it was you should be dead
like you've lived too long you've you've
outlived your your time is up basically
um
you're awake and she was like didn't you
just have surgery and i was like yeah i
just had the breast she's like oh yeah
yeah yeah okay this is totally normal oh
my gosh so
your body and your brain i can't explain
how
google that [ __ ] duckduckgo whatever it
is
your body thinks you're dead
because someone was cutting into your
chest
you know what i'm saying it's like your
carnal reptilian brain you should be
dead on all accounts right when you go
under anesthesia for a surgery
you die
they bring you to the brink to death
they cut you open
a hundred years ago you'd be dead if any
of that stuff was happening yeah you
know it's like our unconscious brain
doesn't understand oh these are all
doctors there's anesthesia this is a
cosmetic procedure like you're not
getting stabbed by a you know or eaten
by a bear so it was like i still don't
know how to articulate it but i thought
that was such an interesting concept of
the idea of like
you know we're a society that now goes
under anesthesia all the time and does
all these like fake murders that we call
surgery
like surgery now
is 100 years ago would have just been a
murder right to our body's brain you
know so it's like
so she was like oh yeah very many people
that i work with after they have
anesthesia like you're supposed to have
someone with you like you can't just go
have a surgery and not tell me because
you know um your body
assumes you died
your subconscious thinks you're dead
yeah and then your conscience is like oh
we're dead
right
is that but that's exactly does that
make any sense it does it does make
sense but it's so
weird like it's so creepy it's very
creepy
i've also had surgeries before and i
haven't had that happen so i but i i
hear what it is what kind of surgery is
though yeah not being cut like twilight
you've been i've been cut in the chest
yes oh yeah no
under general anesthesia is different
right
like a knife in the chest so it's like
a knife in the chest so it's like we
have all these epigenetic sensitivities
you know whereas like if a baby
sees a picture of a spider they freak
out they don't know what a spider is
it's just they inherited that fear that
esther so it's like if
if you're like
getting
if you're under anesthesia and you're
getting cut up even though it's you know
you're paying for it and it's someone
that went to medical school
your body doesn't necessarily know
sort of what's happening and that's the
first time i was like oh my god like
your body might have an intelligence
that your mind doesn't your conscious
mind
are not always necessarily like
corroborating with all the time did you
feel
good the moment you looked down at your
breasts and said yeah this is what i
wanted because i took mine out after two
years oh really i woke up esther and i
was like i hated them there was
something about me that wanted them out
did i know you when you had them in
um possibly yes you did
you did huh wasn't your body rejecting
them
my mind was rejecting them before my
body did like i woke up and i was like i
felt claustrophobic
like i was like [ __ ] get them out it
just did not feel normal i never had
that celebratory moment of like yeah
look at these
oh sh i'm so sorry that i'm late on this
but did when did you
how old were you i was
eight twenty and 29
you just want them bigger basically
um yeah my sister had gotten them they
looked great on her i was very sort of
boxy athlete my whole life so i was like
yeah what about some tits yeah and i i
regretted them as soon as i woke up i
felt like a deep depression about it
interesting yeah that's that is actually
pretty common like why yeah well i mean
this is the most toxic male gaze thing
i'll ever say i'm like you're so hot
big tits on you is you don't need like
it doesn't work like you should have
like bees like you should be this yeah
like big tits on you is just like puts
you in a blow-up doll category so i i
think that that's maybe i don't know if
that's that might have been how i felt
down the road too it was yeah it's a
little like you know i just feel like
this aesthetic like is very
like this um what is that i'm trying to
think of the movie with brook shields
and um
uh
[ __ ]
blue lagoon lagoon
like this blue lagoon
so for me it was like mine weren't just
like small and i wanted them bigger mine
were
grew in different sizes because i had
such bad eating disorders and like the
different sizes of them
like
just constantly
reminded me of that time in my life that
i was really trying to move past and as
i still talk about it today
um
i was trying to like not think about it
and i kind of just was like
i wanted the boobs that i would have had
had i not had an eating disorder because
all the women in my family had like
boobs and that you know and i just i
kind of wanted to just like erase that
part of my history
and
um and so i just wanted to get them
evened out
but
the person i went to was not qualified
to do that so he [ __ ] it up and cut
through a muscle and then i had to go
get it redone so it was like i made an
even bigger mess trying to solve the
other mess look at esther with her
perfect pitch she's sitting there the
only thing i ever prayed for when i was
little was my boobs and you got it [ __ ]
yeah you like secretly have boobs
she they're uneven though too mine are
different as they should be now i know
they every all boobs are uneven and mine
are still uneven i love
i love real boobs big boobs i i say that
just as a
as a straight woman actually
for once as a straight woman that is
coming from a straight place this is
amazing we had the levity we had the
other stuff we're good thank you whitney
for coming and everyone needs to listen
to your podcast which i listen to every
week good for you on youtube
well yeah listen to it is youtube i
don't know i think i'm going to go off
youtube and just do audio
okay listen to it on yeah
forget what i said yeah i might just do
like
yeah i get confused doing both
it just wasn't really made to be
a video thing you know interesting so i
think um
yeah it that's an accidental
thing that happened the youtube space
don't you ever feel like like i've said
him for years like i don't want to i
just want to be crusty and speak yeah
don't want to put makeup on it's
interesting to be playing to both
audiences and feeling like well if i'm
playing for the youtube person i would
do this and if but for the audio person
i would do this and then feel like i'm
disappointing both
yeah i know i know what you mean
i've i haven't stopped asking george to
get us off youtube
[Laughter]
um no i love you youtube i think i'm
just having uh i'm having a day i'm
having a low self-esteem day
[Laughter]
and we'll build you up and yeah going
getting off youtube for a couple days
really does wonders for the self-esteem
i love you guys
[Music]
you